Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Ava and Maria are joined in the woman my voice celebrates. For more than names, they are one name, as two eyes make up a single gaze, and more than hands, the hand held out in time of troubles. And more than eyes, the eyes of she who gives faith with her look, so that the lonely man may raise his face towards her feet and see in the moon and the stars above
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想获取每周独家播客、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。艾娃和玛丽亚在我的声音所赞颂的女性中相遇。她们超越了名字，她们是一个名字，正如两只眼睛构成单单一视，又超越了双手，那是困境中伸出的手。超越了双眼，那是给予目光与信仰者的双眼，好让孤独之人将面庞抬起，望向她的足下，在头顶的明月与繁星中看到
the earth of our fatherland. Ava and Maria, Maria Ava transfigured into hope. So that was Glory by the Peronist writer, José María Castanheira de Dios, which he wrote in 1951. And Dominic, that's one of your favorite poems, isn't it? It's a very strange poem, Tom. I think I, as I told you, a bizarre and terrible poem. And José Mireille Castanero de Dios was actually quite a serious poet. He lived until his 90s. He was kind of a fated. So what was he thinking? Argentine writer.
我们祖国的土地。艾娃和玛丽亚，玛丽亚与艾娃幻化成希望。以上是庇隆主义作家何塞·玛丽亚·卡斯塔涅拉·德·迪奥斯于1951年创作的诗作《荣耀》。多米尼克，这是你最喜欢的诗之一，对吧？ Tom，这是一首非常奇怪的诗。正如我所告诉你的，我觉得这是一首荒诞而可怕的诗。而何塞·米雷耶·卡斯塔涅罗·德·迪奥斯其实是一位相当严肃的诗人。他活到了九十多岁。他有点像个既定人物。所以他在想什么呢？阿根廷作家。
Well, he was a member as a young man of this official Eva Perón poet circle, and they would meet at the headquarters of her foundation every week, I think, or every month. And they would read poems about Eva Peron. And the fact that somebody who's actually quite a serious literary figure was writing this unbelievable nonsense. Dross. Yeah, dross is the word. It reminds me a bit of the ode to Nicola Sturgeon that schoolchildren did on TV a few months into the pandemic.
嗯，他年轻时是官方的伊娃·庇隆诗歌圈的成员，我想他们每周或每个月都会在她的基金会总部见面。他们会朗诵关于伊娃·庇隆的诗歌。事实上，一个相当严肃的文学人物却在写这种难以置信的废话。垃圾。对，垃圾就是这个词。这让我想起几个月前大流行期间，中小学生在电视上对尼古拉·斯特金唱的颂歌。
Very similar figures. Where they kind of hailed her. Well, yeah, a certain similarity. And Maria, presumably, is the Virgin in that. Well, I think the thing is Maria was one of her names. So it's a sort of play on the fact that Maria is one of her names, but also Maria is obviously the Virgin. And the stuff about looking towards her, she gives faith with her look. You raise your face towards her feet. She's transfigured into hope. I mean, there's obvious Catholic resonances there, aren't there? Which are there by this point.
非常相似的人物。他们有点在吹捧她。嗯，是的，有某种相似性。而玛丽亚，大概是指诗中的圣母吧。嗯，我觉得情况是这样的，玛丽亚是她的名字之一。所以这有点像个双关，因为玛丽亚是她的名字之一，但玛丽亚显然也是圣母。至于那些关于仰望她、她的目光给予信仰的内容。你把脸抬向她的足下。她幻化成了希望。我的意思是，这里有很明显的基督教天主教共鸣，对吧？这时候已经有了。
So this is 1951 that he writes this, as you said. By that point, the cult of Evita. We never talked about Evita. Evita kind of means dear little Ava kind of thing. Kind of affectionate diminutive. Eva Kins. Eva Kins is a bit unlikely, but it's a kind of affectionate diminutive. Eva Kins. Eva Kins is a bit unlikely, but it's a kind of affectionate diminutive. And I think the cult of Evita by this point in 1951 has become very, very firmly
所以这是1951年他写的这首诗，正如你所说。到了那个时候，对埃维塔的崇拜。我们从不谈论埃维塔。埃维塔有点像“亲爱的小艾娃”的意思。带有某种亲昵的爱称。小艾娃们。小艾娃们这种说法有点不太可能，但它是一种亲昵的爱称。小艾娃们。小艾娃们这种说法有点不太可能，但它是一种亲昵的爱称。我想，到了1951年这个时候，对埃维塔的崇拜已经变得非常非常稳固
established. So predated her death. In the last episode, we were talking about, thanks to her, the efforts of her foundation, people were saying she's the Lady of Hope, the Bridge of Love, which was her favorite nickname, apparently. I mean, that stuff is very Marian, isn't it? Yeah. But also, presumably, she's the mother of the nation. She is bestowing care and attention on the people who are like her children. Yes. And this, presumably, is why the ovarian cancer with which she's diagnosed, I mean, must be a psychic wound as well as being
确立了。所以这早于她的去世。在上一集里，我们提到过，由于她的基金会所做出的努力，人们称她为希望女神、爱之桥——显然这是她最喜欢的昵称。我的意思是，这些东西非常具有圣母色彩，对吧？是的。但同时，大概她也是国会议员般的国母。她对那些如同她孩子的民众给予关怀和照顾。是的。而这，大概就是为什么她被诊断出的卵巢癌，除了带来一种可怕的医疗打击之外，也必然是一次心理创伤。
a kind of terrible medical shock. I mean, this is the story of today's podcast, ultimately, the death of Eva Barron. And the fact is that her death becomes much more than a personal event. It's a kind of political and national one. So to go back to where we were at the end of the last episode, that cliffhanger. She had gone to the Abayonada neighborhood to open a taxi driver's union office, and she collapsed or fainted, ended up going to hospital, and basically vanished from the newspapers for four days. So this is the beginning of 1950. And that was very unusual because this is a point
我的意思是，这就是今天这期播客的故事，归根结底，就是伊娃·庇隆的死。事实上，她的死远不仅仅是一场个人事件。它是一种政治和国家层面的事件。所以回到上一集末尾我们停下的地方，那个悬念。她曾前往阿瓦尤纳达社区去为一个出租车司机工会办公室剪彩，结果她晕倒或昏厥了，最终进了医院，并且在报纸上基本上消失了四天。所以这是1950年初。这非常不寻常，因为此时正是她
when she's in the newspapers every single day. And then after four days, they said, oh, she's actually had appendicitis and we've taken her appendix out. There's all the procession of churchmen and ministers going to her bedside. But actually, she's probably suffering from the cancer that will kill her, even at this point. And later on, one of the doctors who had looked at her, who was actually the minister of education in the government, a guy called Oskar Ivanisevic. We love to see some multitasking. Multitasking, exactly.
每天都出现在报纸上的时期。然后过了四天，他们说，哦，她其实得了阑尾炎，我们已经把她的阑尾切除了。有一连串的教堂神职人员和部长去她的病床前探望。但实际上，即使在这个时候，她很可能已经患上了将要夺走她生命的癌症。后来，曾为她诊治的一位医生，也就是政府中的教育部长，一个叫奥斯卡·伊瓦尼塞维奇的人。我们很乐意看到有人身兼多职。身兼多职，没错。
Very impressive. He said, actually, I looked at her in hospital and she was suffering from cancer of the uterus. And we did tests and I suggested to her, you should have a hysterectomy. And she loses it, doesn't she? I mean, she's really, really upset by this idea. The trouble is with this, now we're getting into territory from this point onwards that is quite murky because everybody has very vested interests. They're all telling slightly different stories.
非常令人印象深刻。他说，其实我在医院检查过她，她患的是子宫癌。我们做了化验，我建议她应该做子宫切除术。而她听后崩溃了，不是吗？我的意思是，她对这个想法感到非常非常沮丧。麻烦在于，从这一点开始，我们进入了一个相当浑浊的领域，因为每个人都有各自既得的利益。他们都在讲述略有不同的故事。
But I think it's perfectly possible that he said to her, perhaps not in so many words, he said, there is something seriously wrong with you and we would like to do an operation. And she said, no, no way. Absolutely not. Under no circumstances. I think there might be a slight element of perhaps a paranoia, but also some of her biographers say at that point she sees herself as the mother of the nation and all that kind of thing, as you were saying, Tom. And the idea of such an operation is anathema to her.
但我认为完全有可能他对她说过——也许没有说得那么直白——他说，你出了严重的问题，我们想给你做个手术。而她说，不，绝不可能。绝对不行。在任何情况下都不行。我认为其中可能有一点点多疑的成分，但正如你所说，Tom，她的一些传记作家也说过，在那时她视自己为国母以及诸如此类的人物，而这种手术的想法对她来说是绝对不能接受的。
What's odd about it is that not only had Peron's first wife had it, but her mother, Ava's mother had had it and had been operated on and it had been fine. She was still alive. So it's not like it's a total mystery to her. And isn't she, when she goes on her tours, she's taking kind of cotton wool with her to deal with the hemorrhaging that she's starting to experience. So, I mean, she must have a sense of both how serious it is, but also an awareness that catching it early is the best thing to do. But she wouldn't be the first person in history, or indeed the last, to have something seriously wrong with them and just deny it to themselves. I'll carry on. Maybe
奇怪的是，不仅庇隆的第一任妻子做过这个手术，而且她的母亲、艾娃的母亲也得过并动过手术，而且恢复得很好。她当时还活着。所以这并不是说这对她来说完全是个谜。而且，当她去巡视时，她不是随身带着药棉来处理她开始经历的出血症状吗？所以，我的意思是，她一定既意识到了病情有多严重，同时也知道尽早发现是最好的做法。不过，她绝不是历史乃至现实中第一个患有严重疾病却选择自欺欺人的人。“我继续坚持。也许
it'll go away. Is cancer a cause of embarrassment at that period? I mean, is it? You don't talk about it. I think you don't talk about it. I think there's a combination of not talking about cancer generally, a fear, obviously, that it's a death sentence. And so you don't talk about it. I think you don't talk about it. I think there's a combination of not talking about cancer generally, a fear obviously that it's a death sentence and so you don't talk about it because at this point in history, people are aware of it in a way they had not been aware of it centuries previously. You're not yet at a point where people are saying, listen, we can fix this, even though there's an argument that they could have fixed this. But I think also that particular kind of, you know, anything gynecological is simply not discussed in a very Catholic country like Argentina. These things aren't really aired publicly.
它会自己消失的。”在那个时期，癌症是一件让人感到尴尬的事情吗？我的意思是，是这样的吗？人们不会谈论它。我觉得人们不会谈论它。我认为这是几方面因素的结合：普遍不谈论癌症、对癌症是死刑判决的恐惧，因此人们避而不谈。我觉得人们不会谈论它。我认为这是几方面因素的结合：普遍不谈论癌症、对癌症是死刑判决的恐惧，因此人们避而不谈，因为在历史上的这个时期，人们对癌症的认识已经不同于几个世纪前了。你还没到人们会说“听着，我们能治好这个”的地步，尽管有人认为他们本可以治好。但我也认为，在阿根廷这样一个天主教色彩浓厚的国家，任何妇科方面的问题都根本不会被拿出来讨论。这些事情实际上并不会被公开谈论。
And what about Peron, whose first wife had had this? What's going on there? Well, here's the interesting thing. His biographers, I mean, Joseph Page, one of his biographers, says of Peron, Peron always had a very peculiar attitude towards doctors and medicine. He often said doctors are useless. He came from a family where there were doctors in the family, and there'd been talk of him becoming a doctor. And there are suggestions that he rather fancied himself as a kind of amateur doctor.
那么庇隆呢，他的第一任妻子曾得过这个病？当时是怎么回事？嗯，有趣的地方在这里。他的传记作家——约瑟夫·佩奇，他的传记作家之一——谈到庇隆时说，庇隆对医生和医学一向有一种非常古怪的态度。他经常说医生毫无用处。他出身于一个有医生的家族，过去曾有人谈论过他去学医的事。有迹象表明，他其实挺自诩为某种业余医生的。
And it is possible that he would have said to her, don't worry about it. It'll be fine. Doctors are a load of quacks anyway, because he did say such things. So we don't know. We have no evidence for it, but it is possible. All that we know is when she's recovered from this turn at the beginning of 1950, she throws herself back into her work in an incredibly manic way. Yeah, because she says, doesn't she, I don't have time for medical treatment. Treatments are for oligarchs. She's dramatizing it in a very
并且他很有可能对她说过，别担心。会没事的。医生反正都是一群庸医，因为他确实说过这样的话。所以我们并不知道。我们没有证据，但这完全有可能。我们所知道的全部就是，当她在1950年初的这次病情发作中恢复过来后，她以一种极其狂热的方式重新投身于工作之中。是的，因为她说过，不是吗？我没有时间接受医疗治疗。治疗是留给寡头们的。她用一种非常
political way. But also, also tom her whole life she's lived as a soap opera i mean that's so proper that she made her name in and her politics and her public life she has conducted as it was a melodramatic soap opera and the idea of sacrifice has been there from the beginning in her adult persona oh so you think it might be kind of willed that she's offering herself up as a blood sacrifice or to Argentina? It's really hard to say. People do have martyr complexes. We've talked about some very peculiar characters and the rest is history.
政治化的方式将其戏剧化了。但同时，Tom，她的一生都像是在过肥皂剧。我的意思是，那是她成名的肥皂剧，她的政治生涯和公众生活，她一直都将其当作一出情节剧式的肥皂剧来经营，而自我牺牲的理念从她成年人格的最初阶段就一直存在。哦，所以你认为她可能是心甘情愿地将自己作为血祭奉献出来，或者说是为了阿根廷？这真的很难说。人们确实会有殉道情结。我们在《一切皆历史》中讨论过一些非常古怪的人物。
You know, we've already made the comparison with Catherine of Siena. People who seem to have a kind of a will to sacrifice themselves. Her biographers, Fraser and Navarro, say at one point, of all the distortions that surround Ava Perron's life, the least outrageous and the closest to the truth is the suggestion that she elected to die for Perronism. Wow. I mean, that is a bizarre thing to say of somebody. Yeah.
你知道的，我们之前已经把她和锡耶纳的凯瑟琳做过对比。有些人似乎有一种自我牺牲的意志。她的传记作家弗雷泽和纳瓦罗曾指出：在围绕伊娃·庇隆一生的种种歪曲中，最不离谱且最接近真相的说法，就是她选择为庇隆主义去死。哇。我的意思是，对一个人说出这样的话真是太离谱了。是的。
Even Perron himself said, she worked herself to the bone. I begged her to slow down. She wouldn't. Is this sense she has that she can't afford to lie around in hospital because that's oligarchical? Is it also compounded by the fact that things are starting to go not quite as well for Perón by this point? I think so. I think there's a sense of pressure generally within the regime.
就连庇隆自己也说过，她工作鞠躬尽瘁。我恳求她放慢节奏。她就是不肯。这种认为自己不能躺在医院里的想法，因为那是寡头作风？是不是也因为庇隆在这个时候的情况开始变得不那么顺利了？我想是的。我认为人们普遍能感觉到政权内部存在压力。
We talked in the previous episodes about how Perón took over at a sort of ideal Goldilocks moment for Argentina. The Second World War has happened. There's a great demand for Argentine exports in Europe, but there's not imports coming the other way. But actually, what's happening when you get into the 1950s is prices are starting to go up. The returns they get in for exports are starting to go down. The unions are restive. There's a railway strike, which for the first time means the government is against the unions. So his own kind of heartland is restive.
我们在之前的节目中讨论过，庇隆接管政权时正值阿根廷的黄金时期，可以说是恰到好处的“金凤花姑娘时刻”。第二次世界大战爆发了。欧洲对阿根廷出口产品的需求巨大，却没有反向的进口。但实际上，进入20世纪50年代后发生的情况是，物价开始上涨。他们从出口中获得的收益开始下降。工会开始躁动不安。爆发了一场铁路罢工，这使得政府历史上第一次站在了工会的对立面。因此，他自己的基本盘也开始躁动不安。
Yeah, and he doesn't want that. Now, the thing is, he has changed the constitution. So he has an election coming and that's been brought forward. So it's scheduled for November 1951. And I think there's this sense of a kind of ticking clock towards this election. I mean, it is going to be a democratic election, even though it's slightly managed democracy, the press all on his side. And her allies, when you get to 1951, her allies are calling for her to be on the ticket. Now, this is an extraordinary thing in the context of South
是的，他不希望这样。现在的问题是，他修改了宪法。因此他将迎来一场选举，并且选举被提前了。计划于1951年11月举行。我认为有一种朝着这场选举步步逼近的紧迫感。我的意思是，这将是一场民主选举，尽管这是一场略受操控的民主，媒体都站在他这一边。而到了1951年，她的盟友们开始呼吁让她进入候选人名单。在南美政治的普遍背景下，这是一个非同寻常的事情。
American politics generally. No woman has ever been vice president, I think, in any country on earth at this point. I mean, all the more extraordinary, bearing in mind that in the previous election, she hadn't even been able to vote. To vote. Yeah. What an amazing thing. So the question is, who wants this to happen?
据我所知，当时世界上没有任何一个国家的副总统是一位女性。考虑到在上一届选举中她甚至连投票权都没有，这就更加非同寻常了。投票权。是的。多么惊人的事。所以问题是，谁希望这一切发生？
Who is pressing for it? I think most historians say that because Peronism was so ambiguous, it's actually a struggle within the regime. To define it. Yeah. And that the CGT, which is the big trade union group, which is one of our power bases, and the other one, the women's movement, so the women's party that we talked about last time, they think it would be brilliant for her to be vice president and then presumably
谁在极力推动此事？我想大多数历史学家都会说，因为庇隆主义充满了模棱两可，这其实是政权内部的一场权力争夺。为了给它下定义。是的。而CGT（即大型工会组织，也是她的权力基底之一）以及另一个权力基底——女性运动（也就是我们上次谈到的女性党），他们认为让她担任副总统将是个绝妙的主意，随之而来的可能是
president after that, we don't know. Because that would, of course, be brilliant for them. Now, the issue is, by the time that people are pushing this, she's beginning to look quite obviously ill. You mentioned that she's suffering from hemorrhages. There's no doubt about that. And she's losing a lot of blood and she's beginning to look extremely gaunt and thin. If this is a struggle within Peronism, the wings are basically defined by what the poor, the unions, the people who are getting handouts from Santa Eva. Yeah. And then on the other side, the army.
总统之位，我们就不得而知了。因为这当然会对他们大有好处。问题是，当人们开始推动此事时，她看起来已经病得很明显了。你提到她正在遭受出血的折磨。毫无疑问确实如此。而且她正在失血过多，看起来极其憔悴消瘦。如果这是一场庇隆主义内部的权力斗争，那么各个派别基本上是由穷人、工人工会、那些从圣埃维塔那里得到施舍的人来界定的。是的。然后另一边则是军队。
Of course, the army. And if she's looking emaciated and thin, then I suppose in a sense, she's all the more credible a spokesperson for those who are suffering. Yeah. She's suffering herself. She's the embodiment of suffering. She looks the part. Yeah.
当然是军队。如果她看起来消瘦憔悴，那么我想从某种意义上说，她作为受苦受难者的代言人就更有说服力了。是的。她自己正在遭受痛苦。她是痛苦的化身。她看起来就是那个样子。是的。
Of course, the army are never keen on this idea. I mean, the army, frankly, the army are never keen on this idea. I mean, the army, frankly, have never massively been keen on Peron, even though he's from that number, because a lot of them think he's got above himself. You know, he should get back in his box. And the idea that a woman, his wife, remember there had been that initial attempt to kind of stop, block his career because people in the garrisons outside Buenos Aires said, that woman will take over now you know they are very alarmed and of course for Peron that's a big issue because basically the army are the only people that can bring him down so they're the one group of people yeah that he can't afford to alienate because you know they could shoot him so the whole thing is a really weird story I mean by the way it's not the weirdest story we'll be talking about in the remainder of this series. Oh no. It gets madder and madder with episode after episode. So Peron thinks, I won't make my mind up. I will just let this play out. This is the classic thing,
当然，军队从来对这个想法不感兴趣。我的意思是，军队，坦率地说，军队从来没有对这个想法产生过浓厚的兴趣。我的意思是，军队，坦率地说，从来没有极其热衷于庇隆，尽管他出身于军伍，因为他们当中很多人认为他太狂妄自大、爬得太高了。你知道的，他应该安分守己。而一个女人——他的妻子——的想法……还记得当初曾有过试图阻止、封杀他政治生涯的企图吗？因为布宜诺斯艾利斯郊外军营里的人曾说：“那个女人现在要接管政权了，你们知道的，他们对此感到非常惊慌。”当然，对庇隆来说，这是一个大问题，因为基本上军队是唯一能够推翻他的人。所以他们是他唯一惹不起的群体，因为你知道，他们会开枪打死他。所以整件事是一个非常诡异的故事。顺便说一句，这并不是我们在本系列接下来的节目中要谈到的最诡异的故事。哦，不。一集比一集更疯狂。所以庇隆心想，我先不做决定。我且让事情顺其自然。这就是独裁统治、专制政权或威权政体运作的经典模式，
by the way, about dictatorships or autocracies or authoritarian regimes work. The guy at the top lets the people below have a little squabble and then he sides with the winners. And I think that's probably what he's doing about this. I mean, I know it's his wife, but they are hardly seeing each other at this point. Not because they've fallen out, but because they're both so busy with their different projects. But you say that the army is the only institution that can bring him down.
顺便说一句。高层的人让底层的人去争吵，然后他再站在胜利者一边。我想这大概就是他在处理这件事时的做法。我的意思是，我知道那是他的妻子，但他们在这个阶段几乎很少见面。不是因为他们闹翻了，而是因为他们都太忙于各自的项目了。但你刚才说军队是唯一能推翻他的机构。
But actually the people, if they choose to coordinate themselves and get behind Ava, they can't bring him down, but they can certainly embarrass him. So I'm thinking of all those, the famous scenes on the balcony at the Casa Rosada, you know, the don't cry for me Argentina scene in the musical. There's elements there of the Caesars appearing before the crowds at the Circus Maxima, sort of a coliseum. Absolutely, there is. I mean, they can't bring you down, but they can humiliate you and you have to keep them on board.
但实际上，民众如果选择联合起来并支持艾娃，他们或许推翻不了他，但绝对能让他难堪。我想到了所有那些在玫瑰宫阳台上的著名场景，你知道的，音乐剧中《阿根廷，不要为我哭泣》的场景。那里带有凯撒大帝在马克西穆斯竞技场（类似于斗兽场）向民众露面的影子。绝对有。我的意思是，他们虽然推翻不了你，但他们能羞辱你，你必须把他们拉拢在自己这一边。
And I suppose the risk for Peron is that Ava is their favourite and that without even meaning to, if she appears on the balcony and they feel that Peron is not giving her what she wants, then they can make things quite awkward for Peron. They can. And this is precisely what happens, Tom, actually. So effectively, what happens is there's no decision about whether she'll be on the ticket or not, whether she'll be vice president.
我想对庇隆而言，风险在于埃维塔是他们的最爱。如果她出现在阳台上，而民众觉得庇隆没有满足她的要求，哪怕她并非有意，也能让庇隆陷入相当尴尬的境地。他们的确能。Tom，这正是发生的事情。实际上，结果就是对于她是否会进入候选人名单、是否会成为副总统，并没有做出任何决定。
And the unions decide to kind of force the ante. And they decide, they announce that they will have a huge mass meeting, which they'll call the Cabildo Abierto, which is kind of like the open town hall meeting. And there had been a famous Cabildo Abierto in 1810 when the people of Buenos Aires, which was then very small, kind of gathered to throw off Spanish rule. And they say, we're going to have another one. And it sounds quite boring, but it's an extremely big deal. They bring in an estimated 2 million people into the center of Buenos Aires.
而工会决定将矛盾激化。他们决定宣布将召开一次盛大的群众大会，他们将其称为“卡比尔多·阿比尔托”（Cabildo Abierto），这有点像开放式的市民大会。1810年曾有过一次著名的“卡比尔多·阿比尔托”，当时布宜诺斯艾利斯（当时规模还很小）的人民聚集在一起摆脱西班牙的统治。他们说，我们要再搞一次。这听起来可能挺无聊的，但这是一件大事。他们将估计多达200万的人流带到了布宜诺斯艾利斯的市中心。
Yeah. They basically, if you're a member of the CGT union, they will organize a bus or a train for you from all over this enormous country. They will pay for you to come. They will give you your food. They will put you up in a hotel. They'll even give you cinema tickets. So a great treat.
是的。他们基本上，如果你是CGT工会的会员，他们会为你组织来自这个庞大国家各地的公共汽车或火车。他们会为你支付来访的费用。他们会给你提供食物。他们会把你安排在酒店里。甚至还会给你电影票。所以这是一次极好的优待。
Yeah. And all these people, many of them who've probably never been to Buenos Aires before. So it's left wing to the extent that it's the people, it's the unions, it's a great demonstration, but it's also rooted in deeply patriotic traditions. If it's drawing on the memory of this, the overthrow of the Spanish colonial government and the founding of the Argentine nation. So it's very Peronist in that sense. It is. It's very Peronist. Well, it's also very Peronist and nobody really knows what's going on. And nobody's quite in charge of it.
是的。所有这些人，其中许多人可能从未去过布宜诺斯艾利斯。因此，它具有左翼色彩，体现在它是人民的、工会的、是一场宏大的游行示威，但它同时也深植于强烈的爱国主义传统之中。如果它汲取了这段历史记忆的话——推翻西班牙殖民政府和建立阿根廷民族。从这个意义上讲，它是非常庇隆主义的。确实如此。它非常庇隆主义。嗯，它也非常庇隆主义，而且没有人真正知道发生了什么。也没有人能完全掌控它。
And it's all a bit. So they move it from the outside of the Casa Rosada to the big Avenida of the 9th of July. So that's the sort of massive avenue, the Champs-Élysées type thing in the middle of Buenos Aires. They've got huge portraits 60 feet high of Peron and Evita. They build a bridge of love, sort of a bonkers thing to do. And the afternoon of the 22nd of August, 1951, this place is absolutely full with literally millions of people. And eventually, in the evening, Peron and Evita come out
一切都有点混乱。于是他们将集会地点从玫瑰宫外移到了七月九日大道。那是布宜诺斯艾利斯市中心一条宽阔的大道，类似于香榭丽舍大街。他们竖起了庇隆和埃维塔高达60英尺的巨大画像。他们还建造了一座爱之桥，这简直是一件疯狂的举动。1951年8月22日下午，这个地方挤满了人，确切地说是数以百万计的人。最终，在傍晚时分，庇隆和埃维塔
with all their kind of cronies onto this platform. And what follows, I mean, we don't need to go massively into all the sort of details of it, but it is a really weird ritualistic occasion where she comes out and by this point you know she's obviously dressed in her new style which is the kind of very she knew the suit yeah very austere you know she looks a bit like a kind of secularized nun i always think of this kind of don't you tell them the kind of dark clothes she looks of course terrible she looks really gaunt well she looks ill yeah but she also looks quite i mean she doesn't look terrible in the sense that she looks ugly i mean she looks very
带着他们所有的亲信来到了这个高台上。接下来发生的——我的意思是，我们不需要过度深入了解所有的细节——但这确实是一个非常诡异且充满仪式的场合。她出场时，你已经知道她显然换上了新风格，也就是那种非常——她知道那套西装，非常简朴，你知道的，她看起来有点像个世俗化的修女。我每次看到这种装扮都会这么想，你不觉得吗？她穿深色衣服，看起来当然很糟糕，她看起来真的很憔悴。嗯，她看起来生病了。是的，但她看起来也相当——我的意思是，她看起来并不糟糕，并不是说她长得丑，而是她看起来非常
very striking yeah yeah striking in a kind of wasted way i guess yeah but also she's nervous she has tears in her eyes they're all nervous because i think for the first time and she says i mean she's called the woman who never cries, right? I mean, she famously doesn't cry. So for people to see tears on her cheeks, I mean, that must be quite something. I think so. And I think for the first time, she and Peron, they have almost created this monster, which is the appetite of the crowd.
非常醒目。是的，带着一种因消瘦而产生的醒目，我想是的。不过她也很紧张，眼里含着泪水。他们都很紧张，因为我想，这是有史以来第一次——她被称为“从不哭泣的女人”，对吧？我的意思是，她以从不哭泣而闻名。所以人们看到她的面颊上有泪水，这一定是一件相当震撼的事。我想是的。而且我认为，这是她和庇隆第一次几乎亲手创造了这个怪物，那就是群众的胃口。
This is very the Caesars in Rome, isn't it? Yeah. For melodrama. Yeah. They've created this monster that has a thirst for sensation and they are at the mercy of it because she basically gives this very rambling speech where she says, I just want to be Evita. I would rather be Evita than anything. You know, I don't need to be vice president or something. Yeah. People are,
这非常像古罗马的凯撒大帝，不是吗？是的。为了情节剧的效果。是的。他们创造了这个对感官有着极度渴求的怪物，而他们却任由其摆布，因为她基本上发表了一场非常漫无边际的演讲，她说：“我只想做埃维塔。比起任何事我更愿意做埃维塔。你知道的，我不需要当副总统之类的事情。”是的。人们正在——
is she turning it down? Peron then speaks, the crowd are going mad. She then comes out. Because they want Evita. They want her. They don't want Peron. They want Evita. Right. She comes out again. So that's not going down well with Hubby, is it?
她这是在拒绝吗？庇隆随后发表了讲话，人群疯狂了。她再次出场。因为他们想要埃维塔。他们要的是她。他们不要庇隆。他们要埃维塔。对吧。她再次出场。所以这在丈夫那里可不太讨好，对吧？
And actually, at first, they want her to speak again. She won't speak. The union people basically force her to speak again. And then she gives this incredibly rambling, tear-stained, strange, self-mortifying speech, improvised, where she says at one point, I'm like Alexander the Great. It's a very strange comparison. Remember we said that Perron was a great fan of Plutarch's lives. So maybe there's some garbled discussion about Alexander the Great. I mean, yeah. Forcing Plutarch's lives on women. I mean, that's the
其实一开始，他们希望她再次讲话。她不肯开口。工会的人基本上强迫她再次开口。然后她发表了一场极其漫无边际、泪痕斑斑、充满诡异、自我贬低的即兴演讲。她在其中有一段甚至说：“我就像亚历山大大帝。”这是一个非常奇怪的类比。还记得我们说过庇隆是普鲁塔克《名人传》的超级粉丝吗？所以这其中可能有一些对亚历山大大帝的胡乱探讨。我的意思是，是的。把普鲁塔克的《名人传》强加给女性。我的意思是，这就是
way that Perron gets his girls,'t it yeah well it is as we will discover some very bad behaviors to come in in perron's life and indeed in this series yeah and the crowd are going mad because she's not saying i'll do it and she's given this incredibly you know we've said before the thing about peronist rhetoric is it's incredibly melodramatic but it doesn't actually mean anything you know the bridge of love and all that well i mean as you've said throughout it's like a soap opera script and i suppose in a sense for for evita looking out and seeing the two million crowd and she's having to play the part it must be like seeing her radio audience for her soap operas physically present in front of her i mean it must have been so overwhelming that's how you feel isn't it when you do rest is history live shows that's exactly how i feel yeah yeah rambling my
庇隆泡妞的方式，对吧？是的，正如我们接下来将要发现的，庇隆的人生中以及本系列中还会出现许多非常糟糕的行为。人群已经疯狂了，因为她没有说“我愿意接受”。她发表了这样一场极其——正如我们之前所说，庇隆主义修辞的特点是极其充满情节剧色彩，但实际上根本没有任何实质意义。你知道的，爱之桥以及所有这些。嗯，我的意思是，正如你自始至终所说的那样，这就像是一份肥皂剧剧本。我想从某种意义上说，对埃维塔而言，望着外面两百万的群众，她不得不扮演这个角色，这一定就像是看到她广播肥皂剧的听众实实在在地出现在她面前一样。那种感觉一定是排山倒海般的。当你去做《一切皆历史》的现场演出时，你就是这种感觉，对吧？我完全就是这种感觉。是的，是的。语无伦次地
tear-stained cheek rambling tear-stained performance i am a bridge of love between you and dominant that's what it's all exactly how i feel well at your side this the slightly sinister but ultimately smooth and charming. Brilliant. We shouldn't push this analogy too far, don't we? Bearing in mind what is to come. No, we shouldn't. Anyway, so it's an absolutely bizarre performance. Perron looks furious.
满脸泪痕、语无伦次、满脸泪痕的表演：“我是你和多米尼克之间的爱之桥。”这完全就是——我完全就是这种感觉。嗯，在你身旁，这位略带阴险却又圆滑迷人的——太棒了。考虑到接下来会发生什么，我们不应该把这个比喻推得太远，对吧？不，我们不应该。无论如何，这真是一场绝对诡异的演出。庇隆看起来怒不可遏。
Everybody's really confused. She basically kind of breaks down on the platform in front of two million people who are sort of like a baying mob. They want her to say, yeah, I'll do it. And she just gives this kind of very strange rambling performance. It ends and no one knows what has happened. And ultimately she's forced at the end of the month, 31st of August, so a few days later to go on the radio and to say she's turning it down. Now, some people may be listening to this thinking, this is a weird thing to devote a podcast to, like not accepting the vice presidential nomination what what an amazing story i said before that i've been to the
所有人都非常困惑。她基本上就在两百万狂热叫嚣的乌合之众面前崩溃了。他们希望她说：“好，我接下这个职位。”而她只是发表了这种非常奇怪、语无伦次的表演。演讲结束了，没有人知道到底发生了什么。最终，她在月底（8月31日，也就是几天后）被迫通过广播发表讲话，宣布拒绝这一职位。现在，有些人可能会听到这里心想：把一整集播客用来讲不接受副总统提名，这算什么奇怪的事啊？这算什么惊人的故事啊？我之前说过，我去过布宜诺斯艾利斯的
evita museum in buenos aires this moment like occupies a big section of the museum there's a darkened room there's a screen and there are like people in there really moved it's seen as a seismic moment of self-sacrifice yeah and why are they moved? You know, there's a bit of it on that she doesn't really know because I'm an Anglo-Saxon pragmatist and so I don't get the… What do they feel that she is sacrificing? I think they have all invested in this sort of melodramatic story and they are dreaming of a triumphant conclusion in which she will be vice president and maybe president alongside her husband and the crowd can lose
埃维塔博物馆。这个时刻在博物馆里占据了很大一部分展区。那里有一个昏暗的房间，有一个屏幕，里面的人们都深受感动。这被视为具有震撼性的自我牺牲时刻。是的，他们为什么会被感动？你知道的，其中有一部分她自己其实也不太懂，因为我是一个盎格鲁-撒克逊的实用主义者，所以我不理解……他们觉得她究竟牺牲了什么？我认为他们都投入到了这种情节剧式的叙事中，并且梦想着一个凯旋的结局：她将与丈夫并肩成为副总统，甚至总统，而人群可以沉浸在
themselves in delirium. But why do they think she's turning it down? Because she's being so evasive and she is rambling and she's clearly, it's almost like they're investing in the sheer and emotion hollowed out of meaning. I can't, I don't know whether that's the right way to describe it. Yeah. I've just wondered whether they felt that, I mean, is this an anti-Perron sentiment? They don't think that he's leaning on her? No, I don't think it's anti-Peron. Sinister power brokers are? I think some people in this sort of senior part of the movement think he's giving into the army on this.
狂热之中。但他们为什么觉得她在拒绝？因为她一直在闪烁其词、语无伦次，而且显然——这几乎就像他们投入的是纯粹的、被抽空了意义的情感。我不知道这是否是正确的描述方式。是的。我只是在想，他们是否觉得——我的意思是，这是一种反庇隆的情绪吗？他们不认为他在向她施压吗？不，我不认为这是反庇隆的。是那些阴险的权力掮客在施压吗？我想运动高层中的一些人认为他在这个问题上向军队妥协了。
You know, they're quite aware of what is happening. In a weird way, you could argue it's quite good for Peron. Because by not having her on the ticket, it's like he's saying to the army, listen, when it comes to it, you'll get what you want. There's no need to overthrow me. It's as though I think people by this point, 1951, have invested so much in this kind of cult of Evita. You made the comparison with Diana, Tom. That kind of left me cold as well.
你知道的，他们很清楚正在发生的事情。从某种奇怪的角度来看，你可以认为这对庇隆挺有好处。因为不让她进入候选人名单，就好像他在对军队说：“听着，真到了关键时刻，你们会得到想要的。没有必要推翻我。”就好像——我认为到了1951年这个时间点，人们对埃维塔这种个人崇拜投入了太多。Tom，你把她比作了戴安娜。这种说法也让我有点无感。
I didn't really get it. Yeah. I'm just wondering if there's also political, I mean, left-wing supporters of the Labour Party sodden with tears that Keir Starmer won't promote Angela Rayner to quite the level that they think. Is that the comparison I would go for? That he's kicked Diane Abbott out of the party? I mean, is there any element of that? Well, I mean, Theo, our producer, is better equipped than us to answer these questions.
我其实不太理解。是的。我只是在想这里面是否也有政治因素——我的意思是，工党的左翼支持者因为基尔·斯塔默没有把安吉拉·雷纳提拔到他们心目中的那个高度而泪流满面。这就是我要找的类比吗？因为他把黛安·阿博特踢出了工党？我的意思是，这里面有这方面的成分吗？好吧，我的意思是，我们的制作人西奥比我们更有资格回答这些问题。
Evita is the cross between Diana and Angela Rayner. But we should also, just for those people who don't find that an enticing enough prospect, we will also discuss the extraordinary goings on that surround Evita's death and then the fate of her body we'll be getting to eventually. Tell you what, Dominic, why don't we take a break at this point? And in the break, we can ask Theo whether he feels that that's a fair comparison. And when we come back, we will give the answer. Theo's view on whether Evita
埃维塔就是戴安娜和安吉拉·雷纳的结合体。但我们还应该顺便提一句，对于那些觉得这还不够诱人的听众，我们接下来还将讨论围绕埃维塔之死以及她遗体命运的种种不寻常事件，我们最终都会讲到。这样吧，多米尼克，要不我们在这个时候休息一下？在休息期间，我们可以问问西奥，他觉得这个类比是否公正。等我们回来时，我们会给出答案。西奥对于埃维塔
is basically Angela Rayner. So don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
基本上就是安吉拉·雷纳的看法。所以请不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
还有少量的八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therest launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest of History. I'm sure everyone has been absolutely desperate to find out whether Theo thinks that Evita can be compared to Angela Rayner, the deputy leader of the Labour Party, who perhaps has been
独家加更剧集以及抢先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《一切皆历史》。我确信大家一定急切地想知道西奥是否认为埃维塔可以与工党副领袖安吉拉·雷纳相提并论——后者或许在现代英国的庇隆——基尔·斯塔默的阴影下受到了一点冷落。西奥对这个论点的回应是，我引述原话：“……所以就是这样。”总之，我们接着聊关于她去世的事情好吗？因为这太惊人了。我想我们已经聊够政治了。所以在那个“卡比尔多·阿比尔托”集会的当晚，埃维塔晕倒了，这并不奇怪，她似乎被这次活动的种种情绪折磨得精疲力竭。
slightly put in the shadow by Keir Starmer, the Peron of modern Britain. And Theo's response to this thesis was, and I quote, so there you go. Anyway, shall we crack on with the stuff about her death? Because it's amazing. I think we've had enough politics. So the evening after that, Cabildo Abierto, who Evita had fainted, not surprisingly, she seems to have got completely overwrought
而且她确实病得相当严重。在接下来的几周里，她腹部剧痛，有时甚至无法下床。现在出现了一种诡异的情况：庇隆和他的医生们开始对她说，你
with all the emotion of this occasion. But also she is quite seriously ill. And in the next few weeks, she has severe kind of abdomen pains and some days she can't get out of bed. And there's now a weird thing where Peron and his doctors now are saying you
必须做更多检查，你必须严肃对待此事。而她却经常拒绝接受治疗。当她知道医生要来做检查之类的事情时，她甚至会试图离开大楼。他们终于在9月24日星期一给她做了检查，医生把她拉到一边对她说，她患上了非常严重的癌症，而且已经扩散了，这很可能不会有好结果。真的无能为力了吗？真的无能为力了。他们说首先要做的一件事，绝对必须做的一件事就是动手术，做一个
must have more tests you must take this seriously and she is often kind of refusing to be treated she will actually try to leave the building when she knows the doctors are coming to do tests and things they finally do them on the monday the 24th of september the doctors take her on aside and they say she has got very serious cancer and it has spread and this probably isn't going to end well. There's nothing we can really do? Nothing we can really do. They say the first thing we have to do, we absolutely have to do an operation, do a
子宫切除术。我的意思是，这是任何人遇到这种情况下标准的做法。顺便说一句，这距离那场盛大的公开集会还不到一个月。而她是反对的。他们对她说，你必须先服药。她拒绝吃药。他们说，要么我们不吃药直接手术，要么你吃药。于是她同意吃药。
hysterectomy. I mean, that's the standard thing that anyone does on this occasion. And this is less than a month, by the way, after that huge public meeting. And she is against it. They said to her, you will have to have drugs first. She refuses to take the drugs. They say, we will operate without the drugs or you take the drugs. So she agrees to take the drugs.
但就在她服药并接受输血的同时，爆发了针对庇隆统治的第一次真正意义上的叛乱。这是一场由一个叫本杰明·梅嫩德斯的人组织的一场非常混乱的政变。他们一开始没有把这件事告诉埃维塔，直到政变被平息之后。但随后他们把她拉到了广播电台前。或者她是自己要求上广播的？我们其实并不知道。也许她是作为那种自我牺牲的一部分自己要求的？她生平第一次公开谈论自己的病情，并表示她正在祈求上帝恢复她的健康，以便她能够支持庇隆和“无衣民”（descamisados），即她的核心群众、
But then while she's taking the drugs and she's having a blood transfusion, you have the first real rebellion against Peron's rule. So this is a very disorganized coup organized by a guy called Benjamin Menendez. And they don't tell Evita about it at first until the coup has been defeated. But then they drag her onto the radio. Or does she ask to go on the radio herself? We don't really know. Maybe she asks herself as part of that self-sacrifice thing. And she first time talks publicly about her ill health. And she says she's praying to god to restore her health so that she can support peron and the descamisados her her heartland
她的人民、赤膊的追随者们。是的。所以从那个时刻开始，政变和病情这两件事结合在一起，我们开始踏入这场关于埃维塔之死的公开心理剧，因为从这一刻起——1951年12月——你知道的，人们开始为她举行弥撒，举办烛光守夜活动以及诸如此类的事情。这里面是不是有一种莎士比亚式的特质，就好像在莎士比亚的作品中，国王的身体常常被视为国家状况的隐喻？是的，我想是的。而且她的病痛是政府乃至整个阿根廷病情的一种外化，你觉得呢？
her people the shirtless ones shirtless followers yeah and so from that point onwards the combination of those two things the coup and the ill health we start to embark on this public psychodrama of the death of evita because people from this point on was december 1951 you know they start to embark on this public psychodrama of the death of Evita because people from this point on was December 1951. You know, they start to have masses for her. They have candlelit vigils and all this kind of thing. And is there a kind of maybe a Shakespearean quality in the sense that in Shakespeare, the king's body is often seen as a metaphor for the state of the nation? Yeah, I think so. And that her sickness is expressive of a sickness in the government and in Argentina more generally, do you think? And
这正是其中紧密相连的一部分。我确实这么认为，Tom。我认为这不仅仅是国王的身体。这也是一种关于女性身体的观念，将其视为一个常常被男性投射幻想、欲望等种种事物的场所。我的意思是，你不需要成为某种超级女性主义批评家，就能看出其中的共鸣，我想是的。是的。人们会——例如，在布宜诺斯艾利斯郊外有一个叫卢汉的地方，那里有一座仿哥特式的圣殿，里面供奉着卢汉圣母，当然，她曾向某人显灵并创造了奇迹。这是阿根廷最受欢迎的朝圣地。
that that's part of what's tied up with it. I do think so, Tom. I think it's not just a king's body. It's also kind of the idea of a woman's body as a kind of place onto which often men project fantasies, desires, all those kinds of things. I mean, you don't have to be a sort of super feminist critic, you know, to see the resonance of that, I guess. Yeah. People do, for example, there's a place called Lujan outside Buenos Aires where there's this sort of mock Gothic basilica where there's a virgin of Lujan, of course, who appeared
我的意思是，我觉得这太让人不安了。那些本身病得很重的人会为埃维塔去卢汉朝圣。所以典型的现象是，那些断了腿的人据说会步行走到那里。哦，哇。他们会完成某种壮举。他们会进行一次牺牲，因为他们认为这能从圣母玛利亚那里获得某种功德。他们身上会有各种铭文。他们会抬着巨大的圣母玛利亚雕像，上面写着铭文：“为了埃维塔的健康”（Por la salud de Evita）。人们开始——那些无法出行的人会在街上搭建祭坛，摆上蜡烛和圣母像，同样是为了埃维塔。所以，这距离她宣布不接受副总统提名仅仅几周时间。人们有一种感觉，仿佛她在政治上虽然不接受，但实际上人们
to somebody and did miracles. And it's the most popular pilgrimage site in Argentina. I mean, I find this so unsettling. People who are themselves very sick will make pilgrimages to Lujan for Evita. So the classic thing is people with broken legs will supposedly walk there. Oh, wow. And they'll perform a feat. They'll do a sacrifice because they think this will get sort of credit from the Virgin Mary. And they will have kind of inscriptions. They will carry huge Virgin Mary sort of statues
向某人显灵并创造了奇迹。这是阿根廷最受欢迎的朝圣地。我的意思是，我觉得这太让人不安了。那些本身就很重病的人会为了艾薇塔去卢汉朝圣。所以经典的情况是，据说腿骨折的人会走到那里。哦，哇。他们会完成一项壮举。他们会进行牺牲，因为他们认为这能从圣母玛利亚那里得到某种功德。他们会有各种铭文。他们会抬着巨大的圣母玛利亚雕像
with the inscription, Por la salud de Evita, for the health of Evita. And people will start putting, who don't travel, will put up altars in the street with candles, with the effigies of the Virgin, again, for Evita. So this is, you know, within weeks of her saying she wouldn't take the vice presidential nomination. And there's a sense that almost she's not going to do it politically, but actually people
上面写着“为了艾薇塔的健康”。人们开始在街上设立神龛，点燃蜡烛，摆放圣母的塑像，同样也是为了艾薇塔。所以，你知道的，在她宣布不接受副总统提名的几周内就是这样。有一种感觉，几乎是说她在政治上不会这么做，但实际上人们
are pouring that emotional energy into this sort of, you know, overtly religious campaign to try and save her life. So it is all very... Intense. It's very intense. It is very intense. Yeah intense it's very intense it is very intense yeah it's incredibly intense she has her last 17th of october loyalty rally which is the anniversary of the day that they'd had that first big thing with perron when his bosses are trying to kick him out yeah in
把这种情感能量倾注到这种，你知道的，公开的宗教运动中，试图挽救她的生命。所以这一切都非常……激烈。非常激烈。非常激烈。是的，非常激烈，非常激烈，非常激烈，是的，极其激烈。她迎来了她最后一次，10月17日的效忠集会，这也是他们与贝隆第一次发生大事、当时贝隆的老板们正试图赶他走的那天的周年纪念，是的，在
which she hadn't actually played a major part but by now everyone assumes that she has so and now a million and a half people in the center of Argentina. They've dosed her up on morphine. She is there. She's now shrunk so much. She's in this suit that's kind of hanging off her. Peron makes a tribute to her. From this point on, people are basically talking about her as though she's already dead.
中，她其实并没有扮演主要角色，但到现在为止，所有人都认为她扮演了。因此，此时阿根廷市中心聚集了一百五十万人。他们给她注射了大量吗啡。她就在那里。她现在瘦得不成样子。她穿着那套快要挂在她身上的衣服。贝隆向她致敬。从这一点开始，人们基本上谈论她时，就像她已经是个死人一样。
So Peron is giving basically her obituary while she's standing there. She's standing there. She starts crying. She falls into his arms. Again, you can see this in the museum. It's treated as though this incredibly sort of solemn moment, which in many ways it is, but it's also ghastly. To me, it seems excruciating in the amount of dramatics we're playing this out in public. But I think she wanted it to be in public.
所以贝隆基本上是在她站在那里的时候发表她的悼词。她就站在那里。她开始哭泣。她倒进他的怀里。再次说明，你可以在博物馆里看到这一幕。这被当作一个极其庄严的时刻来对待，在许多方面确实如此，但它也令人毛骨悚然。在我看来，以这种公开上演的戏剧性程度来看，这简直是折磨。但我认为她希望这一切在公众面前发生。
There's a sense in which her story, in which her public story, in which she has invested so much, must now proceed towards its preordained conclusion. And it must be witnessed by her people. Exactly. Now, the thing is, to the people who had never liked her, we talked before about the great writer Borges. Borges despised the Perrons.
某种程度上，她的故事，她的公众故事，她投入了如此之多的故事，现在必须走向其命中注定的结局。而且必须由她的人民来见证。没错。问题是，对于那些从来不喜欢她的人来说——我们之前谈到过伟大作家博尔赫斯。博尔赫斯鄙视贝隆夫妇。
He despised Evita. And for somebody like him, Anglophile. Understatement. Tweed. Tweed. I was going to say tweed. Thinking about Kipling him, Anglophile. Understatement. Tweed. Tweed. I was going to say tweed. Thinking about Kipling, whatever he's doing. Horrendous.
他鄙视埃维塔。对于像他这样的人来说，是个英国文化爱好者。这话说轻了。花呢。花呢。我本来想说花呢。想到吉卜林，不管他在做什么。太可怕了。
He finds this unbelievably ghastly. Just common, embarrassing. Gauche. Morkish. Yeah. But I think for most ordinary Argentines, they actually regard it as incredibly moving. This woman, they think, has willingly sacrificed her health and her life for her foundation, for her work,
他觉得这简直令人毛骨悚然。就是粗俗、尴尬、不得体、做作。是的。但我认为对于大多数普通阿根廷人来说，他们实际上认为这极其感人。他们认为，这个女人为了她的基金会、为了她的工作，甘愿牺牲自己的健康和生命，
and now she's determined to die in public. And they must all, there's almost a sort of, I can't remember whether or not I used this phrase in a previous episode, but I remember writing it down while I was reading up on it. There's a kind of totalitarianism of sentimentality about the Peronist regime, I think. So a sense that you must, you absolutely must subscribe There's a kind of totalitarianism of sentimentality about the Peronist regime, I think. Yeah.
而现在她决心在公众面前死去。他们所有人都——几乎有一种，我记不清自己在前一集里有没有用过这个短语，但我记得在查阅相关资料时把它记了下来。我认为，庇隆主义政权有一种“情感的极权主义”。因此，有一种感觉，你必须、绝对必须去订阅——我认为，庇隆主义政权有一种“情感的极权主义”。是的。
So a sense that you must, you absolutely must subscribe to this high emotional drama, which is Diana, 1997, Tom. Absolutely. Yes. And so the conjunction of the film of Evita coming out in 1996 and then Diana dying in 1997 brought that home very forcibly, I think. Yeah. So of course, Peron wins the election in November. There is a scene described by an anti-Peronist writer.
所以，这种感觉就是你必须、绝对必须认同这种高度的情感戏剧，这就像1997年的戴安娜王妃一样，汤姆。绝对是。是的。因此，1996年上映的电影《贝隆夫人》与1997年戴安娜的去世这两件事结合在一起，非常强烈地把这一点带回了现实，我想。是的。所以当然，贝隆在11月的选举中获胜了。有一个由反贝隆主义作家描述的场景。
She was in hospital at this point. But she votes, doesn't she? And it's the only time that she votes. A special ballot box was made for her and brought to the hospital. She votes in this ballot box. They take it outside. And this radical writer, David Vignes, said afterwards, he said, I saw women outside on their knees
她当时在医院里。但她投票了，对吧？这是她唯一一次投票。专门为她制作了一个投票箱并带到了医院。她在这个投票箱里投了票。他们把它拿了出去。这位激进派作家大卫·比涅斯事后说，他说，我看到外面的女人跪在
praying on the sidewalk and they kept touching the ballot box that held Evita's vote and kissing it. A fascinating scene worthy of a book by Tolstoy. Yeah. And it is a really weird scene, isn't it? People praying to this ballot box. I mean, he's fascinated by the scene, but he's simultaneously made nauseous by the toadying of her admirers.
人行道上祈祷，她们不断地抚摸着装着埃维塔选票的投票箱并亲吻它。这是一个引人入胜的场景，足以写进托尔斯泰的书里。是的。这确实是一个非常诡异的场景，不是吗？人们向这个投票箱祈祷。我的意思是，他对这个场景着迷，但与此同时，他又对她崇拜者的奴颜婢膝感到恶心。
So there's a kind of conflict there. So over the next few months, her health continues to decline, but she doesn't die. So actually the terrible thing for her, just on a human level, is that this is quite a protracted scene. And actually by early 1952, she is still being dragged out or dragging herself out to give speeches on the balcony of the Casa Rosada. But she must be dragging herself out because as we've been saying, you know, all her suffering has no meaning if it's not public. Well, maybe a bit of both. It doesn't hurt the regime to keep dragging her out, by the way, because Argentina is now beginning to get into deeper and deeper kind of economic waters. Yeah. So it doesn't help for people to be distracted by this great drama.
所以这其中存在一种冲突。因此，在接下来的几个月里，她的健康状况继续恶化，但她并没有死。所以实际上，对她而言最糟糕的事情，仅从人性的层面来看，这是一个相当漫长的过程。事实上，到1952年初，她仍然被拉出来或者自己挣扎着出来在玫瑰宫的阳台上发表演讲。但她一定是在挣扎着出来，因为正如我们一直所说的那样，你知道，如果她的所有苦难不是公开的，那就没有意义。嗯，也许两者都有点吧。顺便说一句，不断把她拉出来对政权没有坏处，因为阿根廷现在开始陷入越来越深的经济困境。是的。所以人们不被这个巨大的戏剧所分散注意力，这对政权是有利的。
She is now on a lot of drugs and she's an enormous amount of pain and her speech has become sort of darker and darker now so for the first time really she is really talking violently if it is necessary we will execute justice with their own hands. I will leave nothing standing that is not for Peron. And then here's an extraordinary one. May, May 1952. Those who believe in sweetness and love forget that Christ said, I have come to earth to bring fire so that it may burn more. He gave us an example of fanaticism. And for that reason, we must be fanatics for Perron until death. And doesn't she also, from her sickbed, kind of order thousands and thousands of pistols and
她现在服用了大量的药物，处于巨大的痛苦之中，她的演讲现在变得越来越阴暗，所以她真的是第一次开始发表带有暴力色彩的言论：如果有必要，我们将用自己的双手执行正义。我不会留下任何不属于贝隆的东西。接下来是一个非同寻常的例子。1952年5月。那些相信温柔与爱的人忘记了基督曾说过，我来到世上是为了带来烈火，好让它燃烧得更旺。他给我们树立了狂热的榜样。正因如此，我们必须为贝隆狂热至死。难道她不是还从病榻上，下令购买成千上万的手枪和
machine guns and things with the aim of giving them to the trade unions? Oh, I never heard that, Tom. That is an interesting detail. And behind Perron's back. Behind Perron's back, she's doing this. And then after her death, Perron kind of finds out about this and goes and gets them all back. But she is, I mean, she's not just talking about violence. She's preparing for violence. If it's, I mean, literally the last thing she does. So this is an interesting thing.
机关枪之类的东西，目的是把它们发给工会吗？哦，我从未听说过这个，汤姆。这是一个有趣的细节。而且是在贝隆背后。她在贝隆背后做这件事。然后在她死后，贝隆知道了这件事，并把它们全都收回了。但她，我的意思是，她不只是在谈论暴力。她在为暴力做准备。如果这是——字面意思，这是她做的最后一件事情。所以这是一件有趣的事情。
There's definitely an apocalyptic tone to her rhetoric in the last year or months of her life. And this will be important later on, because later on in the last year or months of her life and this will be important later on because later on in the 1960s and 1970s as argentina slides into terrorism and virtual civil war people will will brandish this and they will this is this evita that young people will turn to the radical the violent the terrorist that's what people will get very excited about so let's um move forward towards the the close of her story so we get towards just before that i mean before she dies i said you know about 10 minutes back that there are very brutal attempts to keep her alive
在她的生命或最后几个月里，她的言论中绝对有一种末日般的基调。这在以后会很重要，因为在后来，在20世纪60年代和70年代，当阿根廷滑向恐怖主义和实质上的内战时，人们会挥舞这个，他们会——这就是这个埃维塔，年轻人会转向激进分子、暴力分子、恐怖分子，这就是让人们感到非常兴奋的东西。所以让我们……推进到她故事的尾声，就在那之前——我的意思是，在她死前，我大概在10分钟前说过，为了让她活着，人们曾进行了非常残酷的尝试，
and one of these is radiotherapy oh yeah which basically just kind of leaves her horribly singed doesn't it they apply it very incompetently, so they basically burn her. Yeah. Yeah. And the other one is a lobotomy. This is a story that came out maybe six or seven years ago, I think. An American surgeon said that he had been brought in and given a lobotomy to Evita. Yeah.
其中之一就是放射疗法，哦，是的，这基本上只是把她烤得面目全非，对吧？他们应用得非常不专业，所以基本上把她烧伤了。是的。是的。另一个是脑白质切除术。这是一个大约六七年前才曝光的故事，我想。一位美国外科医生说他曾被请来对埃维塔实施脑白质切除术。是的。
Which must have been licensed by Peron. And I remember when we were talking about this happened with the kennedys didn't it one of um jfk's sisters got had a lobotomy that's right his sister this was a kind of standard medical procedure to try and release pressure on the brain yeah i didn't know about the lobotomy tom i haven't heard that story well it's it's debated right there are people who think it didn't happen yeah I think probably the balance of opinion now is that it did. I mean, if it did, then it's a measure of how increasingly desperate the attempts are to try and keep her from death. Well, you know what her critics, Perron's critics were saying at
这肯定是得到了贝隆的批准。我记得当我们讨论这件事时，肯尼迪家族也发生过类似的事，对吧？约瑟夫·P·肯尼迪的女儿之一就做过脑白质切除术，没-错，他的女儿，这是一种标准的医疗程序，试图减轻大脑的压力，是的。我不知道脑白质切除术的事，汤姆，我没听过这个故事。好吧，这还在争论中，对吧？有人认为它没有发生。是的。我想现在的普遍看法可能倾向于它确实发生了。我的意思是，如果真的发生了，这就说明了为了阻止她走向死亡，人们的尝试是多么的绝望。好吧，你知道她的批评者，贝隆的批评者们在
this point. So in the Barrio Norte, which is the bit of Buenos Aires, the posh bit where all the kind of Anglophiles live, they were saying, the rumor was rumor was people said if you have young children don't take them to hospital because they are taking children's blood she needs young fresh blood and they are literally pumping it into her the quality of the vampire someone who is undead uh who despite being dead has the bloom of seeming life on her cheeks. I mean, this is a theme that will run and run into our final episode. In a very bizarre and unsettling way in the next episode. Yeah, of course, there is immense displays of love for her,
这个时候是怎么说的。所以在北区，也就是布宜诺斯艾利斯的那片高档区域，所有那些英国文化爱好者居住的地方，他们都在说，谣言是，人们说如果你有小孩子，不要带他们去医院，因为他们在抽取小孩的血液，她需要年轻新鲜的血液，他们正字面意义上把它抽进她的体内。吸血鬼的特质，一个不死之人，尽管已经死去，双颊却依然带着看似生命的红晕。我的意思是，这个主题将一直延续到我们的最后一集。在下一集中以一种非常诡异和不安的方式呈现。是的，当然，人们对她展现出了巨大的爱戴，
but there are displays of hatred as well. So, you know, there's graffiti going up in the posher areas of Buenos Aires saying, Viva el cancer. Yeah, I mean, by the summer of 1952, you could argue that argentina has gone completely bonkers that there are just constant parades processions masses congress has a special session names her the spiritual leader of the nation cities entire cities are changing their name
但也有仇恨的表露。所以，你知道的，布宜诺斯艾利斯的高档区域出现了涂鸦，写着“万岁癌症”。是的，我的意思是，到1952年夏天，你可以说阿根廷已经彻底疯了，到处都是源源不断的游行、列队、弥撒，国会召开特别会议，尊她为民族精神领袖，城市，整座城市都在改名
to ava perron at this point that congress that Congress approves a massive monument to her, all this kind of stuff. On the Sunday, the 20th of July, they held a huge public mass, a massive altar is set up by the Obelisk in Buenos Aires and their guy, her confessor, a guy called Father Hernan Benitez, comes out and gives a speech about her.
为“艾娃·贝隆”，此时国会批准了一座为她而建的宏伟纪念碑，诸如此类的事情。在7月20日星期日，他们举行了一场盛大的公众弥撒，布宜诺斯艾利斯的方尖碑旁搭建了一个巨大的祭坛，他们的神父，一个名叫埃尔南·贝尼特斯神父的人出来发表了关于她的演讲。
And she apparently had been looking forward to this. She was greatly looking forward to it. She's too ill to attend. She listens from her hospital bed. But because he talks about her basically as though she's dead already, the hospital cut the wires to her radio because they thought it would be too distressing for her. And actually, it turns out she's really distressed
显然她一直很期盼这一刻。她非常期待。她病得太重无法出席。她从病榻上收听。但因为他谈论她时基本把她当成死人一样，医院切断了她收音机的电线，因为他们认为这会对她造成太大的刺激。事实上，事实证明她确实受到了极大的刺激
because she didn't get to hear the speech. So a pretty horrible scene, all things considered. And then on the Saturday, the 26th of july 1952 supposedly she says that morning to her maid she's lying in bed she says i've never felt happy i've never been happy in my life that's why i left home my mother would have married me to somebody ordinary and i couldn't have stood it a decent woman has to get on in the world very mrs satcher very very mrs thatcher actually isn't it anyway she she declined in the course of the day she was given the last sacraments and then
因为她没有听到演讲。总的来说，这是一个相当可怕的场景。然后在1952年7月26日星期六，据说那天早上她躺在床上对女佣说，我一生中从未感到快乐，我从未快乐过，这就是我离开家的原因，我母亲会把我嫁给一个普通人，而我无法忍受，一个正派的女人必须在这个世界上混出名堂，非常像撒切尔夫人，非常非常像撒切尔夫人，不是吗？不管怎样，她在这一天病情恶化了，她领受了临终圣事，然后
8 23 that night the doctors everyone's standing around to the family and stuff and the doctor said to perron that's it she's no pulse you know heart is not beating and as if her life wasn't melodramatic enough her brother juan duarte stood there at the end of the bed and screamed, there is no God, there is no God, and rushed out. Perón apparently just does nothing, impassive. The government announced that they didn't like the fact that she hadn't died on a roundish number.
那天晚上8点23分，医生们、所有人都围在家人身边，医生对庇隆说，就这样了，她没有脉搏了，你知道的，心脏不跳了，就好像她的生活还不够具有戏剧性一样，她的兄弟胡安·杜阿尔特站在床头大喊，没有上帝，没有上帝，然后冲了出去。据报道，庇隆什么也没做，无动于衷。政府宣布他们不喜欢她不是在一个整点去世的事实。
So they changed the time to 8.25 from from 8 23 so that also they could then start all the news bulletins five minutes exactly five minutes early and begin them all with five minutes of silence but not just that day every day for weeks which gives you a sense of what they're about to do because from that point onwards everything stops cinemas theaters restaurants public transport well that's that's how um evita opens is people in the cinema being told yeah it's done it's all over everything everything must stop now there is one person who who is not stopping and this is a man and here we go with the weirdness yeah who has been waiting outside the sort of the bedroom. This is Dr. Pedro Ara, who is a professor of anatomy and is a supreme practitioner of what is called the art of death.
所以他们把时间从8点23分改到了8点25分，这样他们就可以把所有新闻简报提前整整五分钟开始，并且以五分钟的默哀开始所有简报，不仅是那一天，接下来的几个星期每天都如此，这让你感觉到他们接下来要做什么，因为从那一刻起，一切都停了下来，电影院、剧院、餐厅、公共交通，好吧，这就是《艾薇塔》开场的情景，电影院里的人们被告知，是的，结束了，一切都结束了，现在一切都必须停止了。有一个人没有停下来，这就是一个男人，这里我们要说到诡异的部分了，是的，他一直等在某种卧室外面。这就是佩德罗·阿拉医生，他是一位解剖学教授，也是所谓的死亡艺术的至高从业者。
He specializes in embalming people in replacing their blood with glycerin. I mean, he's, he's a remarkable man because he goes around with the embalmed head of a kind of elderly peasant in his briefcase. So that, you know, should he come across any potential customer, he'll whip it out as an example of what he can do. And he had embalmed Manuel de Falla, Spain's greatest 20th century composer. Yeah. Who fled to Argentina after the Spanish Civil War.
他专门从事将人进行防腐处理，用甘油替换他们的血液。我的意思是，他是一个非凡的人，因为他随身携带的公文包里装着一个某种老年农民的防腐头颅。所以，你知道的，如果他遇到任何潜在客户，他就会把它掏出来作为他能做到这一点的例证。而且他曾为西班牙20世纪最伟大的作曲家曼努埃尔·德·法亚做过防腐处理。是的。他在西班牙内战后逃到了阿根廷。
So he's ready. He's ready to serve, to do his duty. And he will play a very large part in what follows. He has been told you must prepare the body for immediate public display at the Ministry of Labour. Peron has planned this before his wife dies. There will be a funeral. So you only need to do the job for a few days
所以他准备好了。他准备好服务，履行他的职责。他将在随后的事件中扮演非常重要的角色。他被告知你必须为在劳工部进行即时的公众瞻仰准备好遗体。庇隆在妻子去世前就计划好了这一点。将会有一场葬礼。所以你只需要做几天的工作
to get you through a few days. And then you must embalm the rest. And this will be on display rather like Lenin at a permanent monument. So as soon as Juan Duarte has had his shouting about God and everybody has cried, Dr. Ara goes in with his assistant and they get to work. They make her body and I quote completely and definitively incorruptible by putting in some glycerin or whatever they do.
让你度过几天。然后你必须对剩下的部分进行防腐处理。这将像列宁一样在一个永久纪念碑里展出。因此，一旦胡安·杜阿尔特关于上帝的喊叫结束，每个人都哭过之后，阿拉医生和他的助手就进去了，他们开始工作。他们让她的遗体，我引用一下，“彻底且最终地不朽”，通过加入一些甘油或他们所做的任何事情。
Then they put it in a coffin. They put an Argentine flag over it, and they put on a glass lid so people can. And the point is this will only, you know, they only need to do this. This needs to get you through in the next few days. Then the body will move to the labour ministry. Now, at this point already, the crowds are so thick that in that move, eight people are killed in the crush.
然后他们把它放进棺材里。他们在上面盖了一面阿根廷国旗，并装上了一个玻璃盖，以便人们可以。关键是这只会，你知道的，他们只需要这样做。这需要让你度过接下来的几天。然后遗体将被移至劳工部。现在，此时此刻，人群已经非常密集，以至于在转移过程中，有八人在拥挤中丧生。
And in the next 24 hours, more than 2,000 people have to be taken to hospital with injuries because they're crushed in the crowd moving her body. So now we're into the national period of mourning. And at this point, I think it's fair to say that Argentina has gone completely and utterly bonkers. So this is brilliant. This is brilliantly done in Ibiza. There's a two-day shutdown of everything like a general strike. The CGT, the trade union movement, says members have to be in mourning for a month. They have to wear a black tie for a month, Tom.
在接下来的24小时里，有2000多人因在运送遗体的拥挤人群中受伤而被送往医院。现在我们进入了全国哀悼期。此时此刻，我认为公平地说，阿根廷已经彻底完全地疯了。所以这太棒了。在《艾薇塔》中这处理得非常妙。有一场为期两天的全面停工，就像大罢工一样。劳工联合会CGT（工会运动）表示，成员必须哀悼一个月。他们必须戴一个月的黑领带，汤姆。
Can I just have a quick sing song? Oh my God, really? Yeah. Yeah, yeah. You feel this is appropriate in such sad moments? But who is this Santa Evita? Why all this howling, hysterical sorrow? What kind of goddess has lived among us? How will we ever get by without her?
我能唱一小段歌吗？噢天哪，真的吗？对，对，对。你觉得在这么悲伤的时刻这合适吗？但这位圣艾薇塔是谁？为什么会有这般呼天抢地、歇斯底里的悲伤？什么样的女神曾生活在我们中间？没有她我们怎么度过？
Well. I mean, beautifully done. It's beautifully done. And very, very germane for someone living in Britain in 1997 as well, as we keep saying. Yeah, as you've said. So one writer, one Argentine writer said this, what followed was a bacchanal of necrophilia. And I don't think it's entirely wrong, to be fair. So they, you see, they had planned for three days a morning.
好吧。我的意思是，处理得太美妙了。这处理得太美妙了。对于一个生活在1997年英国的人来说也非常非常贴切，正如我们一直说的。是的，正如你所说的那样。因此，一位作家，一位阿根廷作家这样说，随之而来的是一场恋尸癖的狂欢。而且坦白说，我认为这并不完全错误。所以你看，他们原本计划哀悼三天。
So you would go to the Labour ministry, you know, you'd go up the stairs and there would be this coffin at the top of the stairs with a glass lid. Unfortunately, what actually happens is after three days, there was nowhere, nowhere near got through the number of people who are, who are so it then continues for another 13 days and the crowds are so fast 13 days i mean imagine said that the crowds queue is 30 blocks i mean this is far bigger you remember their big business with the queue with about the queen for the queen yeah so they reckon i checked this about a quarter of a million people queued to see the Queen. It must have been at least a million people queued to see Eva Peron's body. And all this time, by the way, the restaurants are still not open.
所以你会去劳工部，你知道的，你会走上楼梯，楼梯顶端会放着这口带玻璃盖的棺材。不幸的是，实际情况是三天后，根本没有，远远没有接待完那些数量庞大的人，所以哀悼又持续了另外13天，而且人群如此密集，13天，我的意思是，想象一下，据说排队的人群长达30个街区，我的意思是，这比那个大得多，你还记得他们排队瞻仰女王的大排长龙吗，为了女王，是的。所以他们估计，我查过这个，大约有四分之一百万的人排队瞻仰女王。排队瞻仰艾娃·庇隆遗体的人数至少有一百万。顺便说一句，在这期间，餐厅仍然没有营业。
The cinemas aren't open. Public transport has been shut down. There are giant photographs of her through the city. Every morning, there is a compulsory 15-minute period of silence during which passages from her ghostwritten autobiography are read out over loudspeakers. Okay, I'm going to just give you another bit of song. Okay. We've all gone crazy morning all day and morning all night, falling over ourselves to get all of the misery right.
电影院没有开门。公共交通已经关闭。整个城市里到处都是她的巨幅照片。每天早晨，都有强制性的15分钟默哀时间，期间通过高音喇叭朗读她由人代笔的自传中的段落。好吧，我打算再给你唱一小段。好吧。我们全都疯了，整天哀悼，整夜哀悼，争先恐后地把所有的悲痛表现得恰到好处。
Well, that's what they're trying to do. Beautifully done. Are you complimenting your own singing when you say beautifully done? No, I was complimenting the lyrics of Tim Rice. Tim Rice. A listener to the rest is history, Tom. He must have his head in his hands listening to you massacring his lyrics. Poor Tim Rice. I feel sorry, Tim.
好吧，这正是他们试图做的。太美妙了。当你说是的时候，你是在称赞自己的歌唱吗？不，我是在称赞蒂姆·赖斯的歌词。蒂姆·赖斯。一个《历史其余部分》的听众，汤姆。听到你屠杀他的歌词，他肯定正双手抱头呢。可怜的蒂姆·赖斯。我替蒂姆感到遗憾。
I think I'm paying the fitting tribute. Right. Now, there's one person for whom this is a massive problem. This is Dr. Ara. Of course, because he wants to get cracking on with his sinister potions and chemicals. He's extremely alarmed because he needs to get on with working on the body. By this point, there is a mist that has formed, so condensation between the body and the glass plate at the top. So the body is starting to decompose. So what they're having to do is they keep having to,
我觉得我在致以恰当的敬意。好。现在，有一个人觉得这是个巨大的问题。这就是阿拉医生。当然，因为他想开始使用他那些阴险的药水和化学品。他非常惊慌，因为他需要继续处理遗体。此时此刻，已经形成了一层雾气，也就是遗体与顶部玻璃板之间的冷凝水。所以遗体开始腐烂了。因此他们不得不做的是，他们必须不断地
at night when the crowds have gone, drill holes in the coffin lid to try to clear the mist. But Dr. Ara says, every time you do this, that is interfering with my work. It was incorruptible, but it is becoming corrupted. Finally, on the 9th of August, they seal the coffin up again. There is a huge parade through the streets. The next day, there's another parade. All the desk commanders are at us, all the shirtless ones,
在夜间人群散去时，在棺材盖上钻孔以试图清除雾气。但阿拉医生说，你们每次这样做，都是在干扰我的工作。它原本是不朽的，但它正在变得腐朽。最后，在8月9日，他们再次将棺材密封。街上举行了盛大的游行。第二天，又有一场游行。所有的办公桌指挥官都在我们这儿，所有赤膊的人，
all the Peronist kind of supporters turn out. Two million people on the streets of Buenos Aires, flowers coming down like confetti from the buildings. This is the last farewell. It takes three hours to get through the city, and finally they come to the headquarters of the trade unions, the CGT. And they take the body out, the coffin out, and they take it into this building. And on the third floor, Dr. Ara has prepared a secret laboratory.
所有庇隆主义的支持者都涌上街头。布宜诺斯艾利斯街头有两00万人，鲜花像五彩纸屑一样从建筑物上落下来。这是最后的告别。穿过城市花去了三个小时，最后他们来到了工会总部，即CGT（劳工联合会）。他们把遗体抬出来，把棺材抬出来，抬进这座建筑。在三楼，阿拉医生准备了一个秘密实验室。
Yeah. And he is waiting, Tom, to receive the body. But what happens next is much more bizarre than anyone could possibly have anticipated. So a regular listener to the podcast will know that I'm a big admirer of El Conde, the Chilean film in which General Pinochet is portrayed as a vampire. And that's a very weird, odd, striking film, but it's not as as weird odd and striking as what genuinely happens to the body of evita and which we will be covering in the final episode of this series we haven't recorded
是的。他正在等待，汤姆，准备接收遗体。但接下来发生的事情比任何人预料的都要离奇得多。所以播客的忠实听众会知道我是《伯爵》的超级粉丝，这部智利电影中皮诺切特将军被描绘成一个吸血鬼。那是一部非常诡异、奇怪、引人注目的电影，但它不如艾薇塔遗体真正遭遇的事情那么诡异、奇怪和引人注目，我们将在本系列的最后一集中报道这件事，我们还没录制
it yet but i i would be surprised if it doesn't turn out to be one of the very weirdest episodes that we have ever done it will be coming out very shortly so so that's fine if you don't want to to get it immediately but if you do want to get it immediately and i i think it will be coming out very shortly, so that's fine if you don't want to get it immediately. But if you do want to get it immediately, and I think it will be well worth listening to, you can go to therestishistory.com and sign up there and get it straight away. Because, Dominic, I mean, back me up here. The story is spectacularly odd. You may think that Evita is gone, but the next episode, as Tom said, first of all, it's got vampirism. It's got body snatching.
呢，但我如果它不是我们做过的最诡异的事件之一，我会感到惊讶的。它很快就会推出，所以如果你不想立即收听也没关系，但如果你确实想立即收听，而且我认为它非常值得一听，你可以访问 therestishistory.com 并注册，然后直接收听。因为，多米尼克，我的意思是，在这里支持我。这个故事离奇得惊人。你可能认为艾薇塔已经走了，但下一集，正如汤姆所说，首先，它有吸血鬼主义。它有盗尸。
It has somebody called the Warlock who runs his own death squad. It has terrorism. It has mad cosplaying, people returning from beyond the grave, people who are supposedly dead, but actually still becoming presidents of countries. It is a very, very peculiar story. I think probably the maddest I've ever read up on. Yeah.
它有一个叫做巫师的人，他经营着自己的行刑队。它有恐怖主义。它有疯狂的cosplay，从阴间归来的人，那些据说是死人但实际上仍然成为国家总统的人。这是一个非常非常奇特的故事。我认为这可能是我读过的最疯狂的故事。是的。
All that to look forward to. We will go and have a quick break now and have a cup of tea, and then we'll be recording this and you can listen to it. Hopefully it will be ready for you. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
所有这些都令人期待。我们现在去休息一下，喝杯茶，然后我们将录制这个节目，你就可以收听了。希望它能为你准备好。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《娱乐之余》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的每周必看节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。